>> Kayleigh: SEVERAL TEXAS
COUNTIES ARE GETTING READY TO
DECLARE AN INVASION OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER HOPING TO
TRIGGER A PART OF THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION THAT MAKES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROTECTING STATES AGAINST
INVASIONS.
THIS COMES AS UNITED NATIONS
JUST LABELED THE U.S. MEXICAN
BORDER OF THE DEADLIEST TO
CROSSING IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
AFTER 53 MIGRANTS WERE FOUND
DEAD LAST WEEK IN A
TRACTOR-TRAILER IN SAN ANTONIO,
TEXAS.
AND AS A BORDER CRISIS ONLY
WORSENS THE BITE AND
DEMONSTRATION DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
TAKING ANY RESPONSIBILITY.
INSTEAD OF BLAMING A HOST OF
OTHER THINGS INCLUDING CLIMATE
CHANGE, WATCH.
>> THE MIGRATION THAT IS
OCCURRING THROUGHOUT THE
HEMISPHERE IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
INCREASE IN VIOLENCE THROUGHOUT
THE REGION, THE RESULT OF A
COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
THE RESULTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Emily: DAVID, THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT THESE GOVERNMENTS
FEEL ABANDONED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
ROBERT NETTLETON SAYS OF THE END
OF THE DAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT DOING ITS JOB
AND ITS LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED TO COME TOGETHER WITH THE
SOLUTION.
>> David: WHAT GETS ME MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE IS THE
INHUMANITY.
YOU MENTION THE 53 PEOPLE THAT
WERE KILLED, IMAGINE OPENING A
TRAILER TRUCK AND SEEING 53 DEAD
BODIES.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS
CRITICIZED BY BIDEN FOR BEING
INHUMANE, AND INHUMANE BORDER
CROSSING.
IF YOU GET THE DESIGNATION OF
BEING THE NUMBER ONE DANGEROUS,
LETHAL BORDER CROSSING IN THE
WORLD, 1,238 MIGRATION DEATHS IN
2021.
AND ALL THAT IS JUST A NUMBER,
AND STATISTICS ARE HORRIBLE IN
THE WAY THEY DEHUMANIZE, BUT THE
INHUMANITY OF THIS POLICY FAR
EXCEEDS ANY INHUMANITY FROM
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS.
I MEAN, THIS HAS A RECORD, JUST
IN TERMS OF PURE NUMBERS, PEOPLE
WHO ARE SUFFERING AND DYING AS A
RESULT OF THESE POLICIES.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT,
HARRIS, 1.7 MILLION ENCOUNTERS I
KNOW STATISTICS ARE HARD FOR US
TO APPRECIATE BUT EACH ONE IS A
LIFE WITH THE FAMILY IN THE
STORY AND WHERE IS OUR
VICE PRESIDENT?
THE START OF THE SOUTHERN
BORDER?
WHERE IS ANY TYPE OF ACTUAL
COMPASSION FROM THE GOVERNMENT
THAT CLAIMS THEIR POLICIES ARE
COMPASSIONATE?
>> Harris: I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY WE TALK TO PEOPLE IN
CONGRESS WHO HAVE GONE DOWN,
YOUR HUSBAND IS GONE DOWN AS A
CONGRESSPERSON.
WHEN YOU TALK TO AMY OF ARIZONA
COME WHEN YOU TALK TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM THESE
DIFFERENT BORDER STATES, EVEN
FAR BEYOND BECAUSE FENTANYL
MAKES IT A BORDER STATES WITH
TRUE.
SO IT'S TRUE.
YOU GET THE HUMANITY.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE LITTLE
ONES BEING PULLED OUT OF THE
WATER OR THE RIO GRANDE INCHES
FROM LIFE TAKEN.
I MEAN, THEY ARE ACTUALLY THERE,
WHICH IS WHY YOU NEED THE
PRESIDENT AND THE BORDER ARE WE
EVEN CALL HER THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
NOT ACTUALLY TRUE.
BUT, IF YOU PUT THE BULLY PULPIT
THERE, THEY ARE GREAT
STORYTELLERS, IT HAS TO BE
BECAUSE THEY ALL GAVE SPEECHES.
SO, IF THEY COULD SHINE A LIGHT
ON THIS AND SEE FOR THEMSELVES,
MAYBE THEY CAN FIND SOME
ANSWERS.
YOU KNOW, I GUESS IF YOU DON'T
SEE IT YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO ANY
THING ABOUT IT.
>> Emily: RIGHT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT, THE ABJECT
FAILURE OF THIS DEMONSTRATION TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CATASTROPHE AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, THE CRUELTY
OF THEIR POLICIES, AND YET
THEY'VE BEEN TASKED WITH
SECURING AN KAMALA HARRIS THAT
I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ROOT CAUSES.
HER TITLE FEELS FALSE, BUT IT IS
STILL HER TITLE.
>> Rachel: THE HUMANITY AND
LACK OF COMPASSION, YOU'RE SO
RIGHT DAVID.
WAS WE WERE COOKED ALIVE.
THOSE NUMBERS DON'T ACTUALLY SAY
WHAT HAPPENS.
MANY PEOPLE DIE IN THE DESERT
THAT WE NEVER HEAR OF.
THERE ARE CHILDREN WHO ARE BEING
TRAFFIC.
WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT.
>> David: THOUSANDS.
>> Rachel: THE LACK OF
COMPASSION A LOOK AT JOE BIDEN
AND SAY TALKING ABOUT CHIVALRY
IN THE BREAK WITH YOUR LITTLE
1.5-YEAR-OLD, TALK ABOUT LACK OF
CHIVALRY.
OR THE FATHER OF THE COUNTRY OF
THE PRESIDENT CAN BE OF NO CARE
FOR NOT JUST THE MIGRANTS BUT
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU REPRESENT ON
THE BORDER STATES TO FEEL SO
ABANDONED THAT THEY SAY WE ARE
BEING INVADED AND YOU DON'T
CARE.
KAYLEE, LET'S COLLECT OF THE
U.N. REPORT.
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT?
>> Kayleigh: THE AUTHOR OF THE
REPORT SAID NUMBER OF DEATHS AT
THE BORDERS WORSE THAN ANY PRIOR
YEAR, EVEN PRECOAT WOULD.
OKAY, THAT MEANS THE 2021
NUMBERS ARE WORSE THAN ANY PRIOR
YEAR.
WHAT HAPPENED IN 21?
THIS GUY NAMED JOE THE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN ROLLBACK EVERY SINGLE
POLICY.
THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN IN A VACUUM.
THIS HAPPEN WHEN YOU ROLLBACK
REMAIN IN MEXICO, THE STRIP AWAY
TITLE 42, INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
COME.
TO YOUR POINT, RACHEL, VERY GOOD
POINT ABOUT THE NUMBER OF DEATHS
THAT ARE NOT COUNTED, WHAT ABOUT
IN THE GAP, THAT IS TREACHEROUS
TERRITORY IN PANAMA THAT
MIGRANTS COME THROUGH BEFORE
THEY EVEN MAKE IT TO MEXICO.
A LOT OF THEM PERISH IN THE
JUNGLE.
THIS NUMBER IS FAR HIGHER IN
2021, ABOUT DOUBLE WHAT WAS THE
YEAR PRIOR.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF A GUY NAMED
JOE BIDEN, WHO IS NOW THE
PRESIDENT.
>> David: CAN I SAY NOT IF IN
QUESTION WERE COMMANDER IN CHIEF
IS ONE OF HIS TITLES AND BORDER
PATROL ARE GOING THROUGH MISERY
AND HELL AS WELL.
>> Harris: AND I'LL SEE THOSE
NUMBERS ARE BEFORE WE GOT TO
THIS POINT TO WHAT ARE WE ON
TRACK FOR FORMER 2020?
>> Emily: WITH THE REMAINING A
MAGICAL POLICY COMING OUT OF
SUPREME COURT MEANS IT WILL JUST
BE ANOTHER SURGE.
I DON'T SEE AN END.
TO ME IT FEELS HOPELESS, AND
THAT'S WHY THESE STATES ARE
TAKING IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
DECLARE AN INVASION SAYING WE
HAVE NOTHING E